we've imagined that you've received your
share of screenplay pitches or you've
heard about
others pitching what are some of the
wrong ways
to pitch what are some of the wrong ways
to reach out to someone
i think there is a right way and a wrong
way to
present people your work your
screenplays to approach them i think if
you break it down
i think writers need to be just as good
if not better
as writing a synopsis or a treatment i
like getting those two page treatments
where
you know if it's five acts it's a
paragraph per act a title a log line a
brief synopsis and then the breakdown
i think if you can do that and you can
basically summarize what it is you're
trying to say i get
i can tell in two minutes if this is a
story i want to read i don't need to see
a script um
but it's really important that you know
the craft of of writing too
because uh writing is a gift writing is
a craft
and a lot of people don't understand the
importance of good storytelling
and because they've spent a year and a
half writing a script doesn't mean it's
good
and they have to respect a lot of people
get hit with so many scripts
that they take it personally if you
don't want to read it and you know we
all have lives we're busy we have
business life personal life social life
we have all these things in our own work
life
and i always you know if somebody is
kind
considerate and they reach out i always
try to say okay well i'll look at a
synopsis but only if it's copywritten i
need to see the copyright
you know registration receipt i'm not i
don't take anything without that
so make sure you have your work copy
written and
be kind and considerate and realizing
that you're you know
you're you're not the only person who
has a script that needs red
and reading a script does take people a
couple of hours out of their day and
you know how many people do you know
that you don't know that would take two
hours out of the day for a stranger to
just read your script so i just think
it's about the presentation it's about
knowing how to write a synopsis or a
treatment that can lure
a reader or a decision maker to want to
know more about what you're doing is
really important
how often do you receive cold pitches uh
you know it's not that often
um i get i mean i get a lot of inquiries
which i really appreciate i don't mind
people asking i'm an open book
you know anybody can email me info
chainstanley.net i mean i don't care
it's how it's done and it's
for me um when i just get an email
that's shotgun and i know it's shocked i
even look at it i just
you know i just write back and say i
don't accept unsolicited material and i
cc my lawyer
i cc my manager and i write them back
and i say hey you know you sent this to
me unsolicited i am not interested in
seeing this this is not how to do it
appreciate it if you have somebody who
who reps you if they want to reach out
to my manager or lawyer that's a
different story and i never hear back
from them again that's just the end of
it
people who reach out genuinely you know
because i do so much work with the
colleges that you know
i'll encounter a writer three years ago
and then they'll write you know and say
you know dear shane
you gave a workshop at my class in
florida a few years ago and you know i
finished a screenplay and i really
enjoyed your may i send it to you
i always write back and say i'm not
going to read your screenplay right now
but if you want to send me you know
copyright everything i go through
copyright everything i need to see that
it's been registered certified
copywritten with the usco
once that's done i will gladly look at a
treatment and we can go from there and
usually they're pretty cool about it i
don't mind reading those
i don't i'm not going to read scripts i
just don't have the time
and i know that's terribly heady to say
but i just don't i'm a slow reader
shane what are the top five reasons you
will reject a screenplay let's say it's
it's well written it's formatted but
there's just something that's not
working for you
you know in rejecting a screenplay the
first thing writers should never take it
personally
art is nothing but opinion i mean you
think about how many
great scripts got made years after the
fact
after they were turned down and rejected
by so many other filmmakers
it's about first and foremost it's about
the project connecting
with the person you're sending it to
just because i made a movie about
football and had success with it doesn't
mean i want to make another movie about
football
i also want to evolve as a filmmaker so
what's important is is that you never
take it personally
i would hope if i do read a script and i
think there's something there that i
would at least write
i would always try to make it a point to
write the writer or contact the writer
and say look i gotta be honest with you
you're talented
i like what you're doing i know somebody
who i think would appreciate it let me
help you
you know i have no problem with that and
one of the writers that i work with who
i
use one of my favorites to work with is
cj wally he's the the guy that has
script revolution
out of the uk and our relationship
kicked off by reading one of his scripts
that was
beautifully done i would never make the
movie i couldn't sell the movie but it
didn't mean he can't write
and i i read his words i read his the
his setups i read his
you know his character arcs and i just
and i read his theory on breaking down
scripts and doing proper treatments and
synopses and i
this guy had it all together and
for me it was like hey dude i love your
writing
i have a project i'm gonna do i want you
to write it and then we were able to
work together and like you know we've
written several scripts together
and that came because i read a script
that i i would never make
but i knew the writer was good so it's
not always about the script i don't
think spec scripts get made much anymore
filmmakers have an idea what they want
we have actors that we know what they
want to do
we have buyers and sales agents who we
know what they can sell at the moment
and we have an audience trend that you
know right now doing a drama
living in an apartment is not going to
sell we have all been
locked in because of cobid for six
months in our four walls
we want to be outside we want to laugh i
don't want to hear about your problems i
don't want to think about my problems
so if we're selling scripts right now
and you're trying to pitch it better be
adventure it better be funny and better
have romance it better get me out on the
water i want it to get me out in the
desert
i want to go on travel these are the
things that you constantly have to think
about
and writers don't writers are very
myopic
and that's okay we we get in a box
and it's all about this and you have to
realize there's there's actors there's
money that has to be raised there's
directors that have to come on board
there's um teams of people that have to
capture the vision to make this happen
and after all that's said and done is
can it be sold
are there those seven trailer moments in
this script that we know we can sell it
is there an uh an output
worldwide or is this just going to
appeal to one place
and that's these are the things that a
lot of writers don't think about the
business
of the business it's not just whether
your script is good so much of it is
about
where is it going to sell you're still
selling a widget
are you selling a widget that only
appeals to one out of every
5 000 people or are you selling a widget
that everybody kind of needs
and that's how you have to look at it
when making a script
and what are those seven trailer moments
i don't think they're anything specific
i think they're the catch phrases
they're those
hero moments if you're telling an action
story like you take any two minute super
trailer that you see
and you'll see those five to nine
moments that you know are important in
the film they're the
the tent poles of the story they're the
catchphrases
they're that huge explosion they're that
great moment in the car chase
it's it's the sex scene real quick
it's the action running it's it's those
things
and they're not anything consistent but
your story has got to be able to tell
the executives who don't read scripts
and don't know much
it's got to tell them that i can sell
this that's all it is it's
can i sell it um some of the
relationships i have with sales agents
and buyers they don't read the scripts
they want the synopsis
they want mock art you know they want to
see a mock poster that me and a writer
make and in two hours on photoshop and
say here here's your kind of idea for
the image here's your here's your log
line here's your title and they'll tell
you right then and there yeah i can sell
that
that's how these decisions are made
wow so so what why not even
forget the treatment why not just come
up with a great poster
and log on well i think that's but you
still have to have a script to shoot
and finance so ultimately you're going
to need the script um
but i think i think that's all part of
the package because so many people are
from the filmmaker side i don't write as
much but if
i have a writer who's done a script i
expect the synopsis and the treatment to
be
as good if not better than the script
it's got to be because i know there's
there's always three scripts the one you
write the one you shoot and the one you
cut
okay the treatment is what you're really
selling
overall they executives are not going to
read the script i deal with more
executives now they just want to see
they just want a two-page synopsis
and just show me some mock art so i know
what i'm selling and they'll tell you
well
tell me in five minutes i can sell it or
you're gonna find somebody else i can't
do anything with this it's not my
wheelhouse okay
and then we make the decision do we do
we believe in this enough to roll the
dice and
struggle and pull teeth and try to get
it somewhere else or do we
listen to people we trust and say this
is not the one to do
that's our developmental process it's
very quick we don't go through the years
of development or months it's
here's an idea i'll pitch the idea
to my buyers if they like it i say okay
they like it let's do the synopsis and
then i get them the synopsis
sometimes with some mock art and then
they'll either say
okay the idea is good act two i can't
you can't do this in act two this
this i can't sell tweak it this way
and then they'll go oh you know in act
four uh can this happen maybe in act
five it's happening too soon or can you
bring the villain in sooner
those are the kind of conversations we
have and then it just the table is set
and the writer can go do it
and i the script the spec script is very
hard to sell i think spec scripts are
great calling cards if somebody can
write or not
found a tremendous writer through the
community college just
this during covid who i take a lot of
pride and i not only got her a manager
she got a job like writing a script
for hire for a very substantial
production company and this is one of my
zoom students
from the community colleges that reached
out to me
you were asking the right way and wrong
way she reached out to me she had taken
three or four of my zoom classes with a
community college
lovely woman very articulate kind
no expectations just i really appreciate
it i would love to share my work with
you
here's where i want to go in my career
and she's she's an older woman she's
like you know her son's like my age i
mean she's been around
and has worked around the industry but
never
really flourished as a writer
and i finally said let me know when your
synopsis i looked i went oh my god i
know somebody who's looking for this so
i said
i'm not going to read your script send
it to me i'll send it to somebody who
knows this company and the guy read the
script called me up and goes who is this
woman she's really good
and we got her an agent and three weeks
later she actually got to work for hire
on a greenlit film that they green they
had greenlit on the concept
and they liked her writing enough to say
you were you were a writer for hire on
this and she's on her last she's on her
second polish on it and they're getting
ready to go into production i think in
january
it's greenland how common is that
not very but i say that to inspire
because there are ways and again it came
from being kind it came from being a
familiar face it came from somebody who
who reached out with a tender heart and
a gracious heart
to understand and respect my schedule
and maybe i didn't want to read it
and understood when i said i don't want
to read your script but let me
let me look at the synopsis and then
when i was like there's something here i
said
i'm going to send a synopsis to somebody
i think would like this and if they do
i'm going to need you to have a script
ready and that's how it went
is synopsis king in this day and age of
instant information
and being able to get answers quickly i
suggest that it is definitely something
that is put to the forefront
uh going back to people's time and you
know we've developed this instant
gratification
generation of you know getting it on the
phone and i'll get you an answer let me
ask siri i think a lot of us have put
that into our workflow
um i know what my days are i i hit the
ground i am working by
5 5 30 in the morning even when i'm not
making a movie and my wife is usually
saying all right honey come on it's
getting late you've been
you know this is when we're not doing a
movie i just i'm immersed in my work so
taking two hours a day to read a script
it doesn't fit i don't schedule read
days so
my my feelings if you want to write and
you want to get seen by filmmakers who
are
who are busy and i suggest you really
learn how to build a treatment
besides being a good screenwriter learn
how to do a treatment learn how to do a
synopsis
there is a a web platform based in the
united kingdom
called script revolution it was it was
it was created by cj wally
and i find if you're a writer i suggest
you go and check out
it's a free site it's it's i think you
will be blown away on
the the way it breaks down how to write
not only screenplay but the treatment
the synopsis the act breakdowns he's
created some you know the turn and burn
which is this
really cool theory and i think once you
understand that as a writer
your treatments are going to flourish
which are going to make people that are
in a position of making movies
get more excited about what it is you're
doing and what you're trying to say so i
think
the treatment and the synopsis is so
important
the script ultimately is but if i read a
great synopsis and a great treatment
i will be more forgiving on the script
knowing where ultimately this could go
where if i just get a mediocre script
and it's okay
and done i don't see the vision that you
caught me in in a page or two
so i'm a big proponent for the treatment
i'm sorry just real quickly what is the
turn and burn
that's a good question that's for him to
answer i mean if you go if you go on the
website if you go on to
scriptrevolution.com
there is a whole sub-chapter about
turnanburn and is his theory
on how he creates the synopsis and it's
a whole
it's a whole map of like 10 different
sayings that he has
that i could never relay i don't write
anymore
but um it all makes sense and when i
know when i've collaborated with him or
other writers that are
part of his platform it's it's really
it's really about the developmenting the
treatment develop the treatment so the
script process is
is easy it's like as i talked about in
my book the most important thing about
filmmaking is the pre-production time
i i work myself to death during
pre-production so production
is fun and easy that's how it's supposed
to be
you know pro football players will tell
you you work monday through saturday
and you get paid to play on sunday
that's how it should be when you write
that's how it should be when you make a
movie and what they've done at script
revolution
is they have basically given you
training camp hell week and practice
in the treatment side so the writing of
the script is
actually fast efficient and it's right
on point
and there's no surprises and that's what
most
filmmakers development executives get
concerned about is riders going down
rabbit holes they weren't supposed to go
down
going off track if your treatment is in
order
everything is it's expected you're just
filling up the pages
with with witty dialogue with fun give
you an example working on this film
we developed we've got a we've got a six
page treatment
that's the five acts it's the character
breakdown who everybody is what the
point of the show is what's the log line
what's the synopsis
we have gotten four acts in seven days
there's not been one surprise except
happy surprises because we all know
where this is there's four of us that
are involved in
doing the film that are from a
decision-making capacity not one of us
have been
thrown a bump a roadblock a speed bump
nobody's been like oh my god what's
going on and it was because
the way the treatment was handled going
in it's it's
it is so paramount and speaking of bumps
i don't know if you're reading my mind
but i was just going to bring up
goosebumps
it's so funny that was the next thing i
was going to say was that r.l stein i
guess
the creative goosebumps he talked about
how he knows the ending
and he writes this treatment or whatever
and then once he knows the ending then
he can go
back and he can fool the audience and
it's it's effortless writing but it's
just getting that
that structure in place and i know and i
know in the way that they
do these treatments they often will have
17 blank pages and start on page 17 and
work backwards
it's not uncommon and it's interesting
and there's different ways for it to
work for everybody but it's kind of just
basically a way to think about it and i
think once you capture that
whether you're a writer or not you see
what he's doing oh i get it
and too many of us and the way i used to
write when i used to try to hack away
was i would just sit there and come up
with a title and write fade in
and tell my story sometimes i got lucky
and sold a few scripts i did okay
but as i got older my mind wasn't as
fast i wasn't as creative i had kind of
burned a lot of that creative energy
telling stories and then becoming a
filmmaker an editor a producer a
director
or i wasn't just sitting for weeks at a
time writing
so i learned later in life how important
a treatment is
it's it's so important to know what it
is you're going to do
and it's great when you can surprise
yourself as a writer but
to know where you're going to know the
purpose of each scene to know
the arcs and the back stories that
aren't going to be on the page of each
character i think if you as a creator
know all that you'd be amazed the
stories that you can tell it's just it's
just smooth sailing
shane we've heard you say send us
treatment we've heard on our side
people say okay i sent them a treatment
it was a 20 page treatment
is that okay is that too long oh i think
in first pass i think i think you need
to again be considerate
of the reader um when i say send a
treatment
i would like a title i'd like to know
who it was written by
i'd love to see a log line and then i'd
like to see a two-page
synopsis give me a paragraph per act
that's it that's all i need
and i could either say yeah i like this
i want to see a script or i could say
you know what
if you have a more in-depth treatment
breaking down some things
back story on the characters cast size
i'd love to see it that 20 then i would
expect that
10 to 12 to 20 page treatment it's not
that you shouldn't have them i feel when
i say you need to be versed as a writer
in writing synopsises and treatments
those are two separate things that are
equally as important
because i'm only going to read a
synopsis first i just want to see a page
or two on what you're doing
and if that instills not quite enough
interest to see the script but i'm
intrigued enough to say i want to know
more that's when that 20-page treatment
or whatever it is that you've done
is important obviously not a 90-page
treatment then just send me the script
but you know what i mean it's it's i
think the synopsis is king
it's it's just let's let's ignite that
fire spark the interest and if you get
that
have the treatment ready but hopefully
the script is there and tight
good that was a great question because
it is because
some people send you like a paragraph
you're like that's it
you know i always say your synopsis
should just be a paragraph per
you know treatment is a paragraph per
act and then the breakdowns anything but
a synopsis should be about a page and a
half
two pages and and if you need more than
that to tell the story
you gotta you gotta re-look at your
story it's too confusing it's too
it's too long it's too you know it's too
hodgepodgy you gotta
tighten it up
you